hi guys i'm amanda martin from lindsay
sweet deals furniture
I came to vaynermedia because I wanted
to see how they could help my business
we did a few initial rounds of questions
and we felt that we were a good fit for
each other and what you guys are gonna
watch is our first meeting about our
brand and just discussing what we were
doing and getting into a deep dive of
how we operate day to day business and
what we do to try to promote our
business and our marketing and just
everyday operations and it was so
exciting to be in that meeting and go
through with all the Vayner mentors and
really dig deep into our business I
can't wait for you guys to watch this
and hopefully somebody will learn
something from it I had a really good
time doing this meeting and I learned a
lot and we are implementing some of our
tactics and I cannot even begin to tell
you how much it has helped and the
results that we've been getting and I
can't wait for the future and to
implement some more of our ideas and
tactics hope you guys enjoy it bye you
got your perspective don't you want to
be happy
[Music]
I'm such a pleasure how are you hi good
thank you
so glad to see you for two-and-a-half
years my family business was known as
shoppers discount liquors
there was a sign printed on 8 by 10 on
the front sliding door that said wine
library and that's how I 2 and 1/2 years
I traded as winelibrary.com and then
made the shift to Wine Library from
shoppers discount liquors so one of the
things you may want to debate here is if
you're trading differently on.com
building up that brand equity and then
if you decide that brand is something
that you can put on the front of the
building it might be a worthwhile debate
yes it's the easiest way for you to like
solve this potential issue I'm coming in
cold and listening but it's it's being
done a lot like there's a lot of
opportunity to play both fronts and then
you'll have the options to be able to
absorb it and with 85 [ __ ] thousand
square feet even if 20,000 or 30,000 how
much is retail no no some warehouse
right I mean that's unlimited space aka
picking one of the corners and doing
something just like cool with like
coffee and computers and calling it
furniture you know if you call it you
know whatever you call it let's just
call it Orsini's house let's say that's
the brand new rent with calling that
corner like Orsini's cafe there's a
couple tables little fresh coffee
and you've got laptops there and so all
to Orsini's now you've injected that in
your it's an organ within your body that
eventually could become the body
something to think about
the computers the shop the website or
yes it's just establishing the brand
strategically like I you know I would
argue one of the things that may come up
here today is like literally looking at
5,000 square feet to do something
completely left [ __ ] field like like
a co-working space like if you're
selling b2b merchants are you
- bee - bees at all it's kind of an
interesting conversation right like as
startup craze takes over the world like
like I know this is super left-field but
like what if you did have three to five
thousand square feet of co-working space
and had entrepreneurs sitting there the
same way Starbucks has them sitting
there and then that started giving you a
b2b flavor because you have people there
and all of a sudden even like the area
they're in has b2b thinking around Matt
like it's more like do you need a couch
for your office they could just change
the dynamics of different usage for you
look I think there's I think both ways
can work I think it just comes down to
me the bigger question is like what are
you trying to accomplish right you know
so let me ask a different question
what's your least situation where that's
great so that's that I assume that's a
big capital expenditure so I think
you've got to really be smart here
because if you're making that cat you
know that cog move you I do not believe
it's a good buy no matter how good of a
deal you're getting unless you turn the
location to something more than what you
actually do I couldn't say this enough
I'm you're so young I'm so worried about
what your business looks like between a
dot-com and a physical location a decade
from tying up this year that I think we
you know I think what we're what this is
all about it's like pretty either like
like the reason we even built mentors is
I knew that in these meetings there's
anyone the three things that we could
bring that are disproportionately
impactful for what it cost and returned
the number one thing I would tell you is
the two things that you need to kill I
literally don't care about anything else
in your business right now other than
two things one the hell are you gonna do
inside your 85,000 square feet that's
different that has nothing to do or is
come complementary to what you do for
the sake of the business event marketing
like back to be to be like real estate
mark like what if you are the stage for
all real estate events and you're like
you have to figure that out and number
two you have to figure out calm they
every day that you wake up first to like
buying good deals taking care of your
staff taking care of your customers
amazing guess what remember
three four and five number one and two
is what other capital are we gonna pour
into this 85,000 square feet that I get
like you know comes with renovations you
may have to have a separate entrance you
may have to who the hell knows right
I couldn't stress enough of that
importance in parallel you're pulling
from opposite directions you're making a
double investment into your physical and
you're trying to almost eliminate people
from coming in to build up your calm
that religion it's what I did I love
giving advice I took we built a seven
million dollar building while we poured
every asset into building wine library
cut calm into one of the biggest leaders
if my dad was sitting here right now his
biggest concern is like the traffic is
down the end yeah long-term site that's
where I get worried about but I know
that you come is important as well there
is no as well you know we have to build
today
no we gotta think about tomorrow and me
being on the front end of all this
that's what I deal with every single day
everybody walks through that door no
matter how operational they got their
phone yeah I want to have to get it here
yeah for this price I are you willing to
match it yeah I apologize what uh what
are you doing in that scenario
yeah pretty matching pricing I mean a
hundred percent of time if it's legit
you know there's some things that we see
98 versions I had you know I have an
instance other day where I mean you know
make seven bucks I think you're I think
you're making a huge mistake then and if
you have a huge opportunity let me tell
you a story my dad in the liquor
business they of something called the
ABC we we ABC came in one day and
they're like you can't do case discounts
my dad's reaction was to put everything
at 15% off from bottle one so wasn't
even a case this county more in essence
everything was on sale the store was on
sale this store was on sale so some
things were on sale sale like you buy it
was 15 its $9.99 but if it wasn't it was
just a regular item it was fifteen by
default and rung up at the register
fifteen percent off the problem was he
never told anyone we didn't know
marketing so in overnight
one day we became the best price store
in the state yet nobody knew and people
didn't even know because we didn't do
internal signage people were literally
like well I'm just telling you the truth
like people would be like I'm gonna buy
this for 15 you get to the register it's
1314 like a bag you know something by
mistake I am telling you right now I'm
telling you right now
the number one thing I would do right
now temporary banner sign not sign on
the building is have as big of a sign as
the town will let you say that we match
all internet prices little asterisk as
you get closer to the building it says
2% like I would just arbitrarily and you
got to find out the like but I think
it's 2% of times there are some
restrictions or private labels that were
unable to match nobody driving by you're
building a company store thinks that
here's my question if if the truth is if
five out of ten people are actually
doing what you just said I would tell
you that you should go there if it's if
it's one three out of ten but it feels
like every person then you've got a
debate because you've been giving up a
lot of margin if it's 7 out of 10 you
might want to [ __ ] make it a
permanent sign in your building now my
question is what is it really what
you've got time I would say that
actually approaches me or probably three
out of ten but you know it's in their
minds everyone's watching you know do
you believe do you believe they're
looking at the couch testing touching
and then ordering online because I think
that's what's happening yes because
that's what's happening at Best Buy and
Target in many other places realize even
with you can say not just Internet
no we're losing some cells there but
even say the actually home store across
town we sell actually furniture as well
there are certain things that they're
over there in that showroom they can't
find maybe if they like their experience
better over there and they think they're
getting a better price they're in
lindzi's sitting on that sofa walk out
the door go back over there and buy
who's a better price who's who's who's
the better price you or them I'll lead
them up and down the road every day
that's when we go to like our Ashley
reps they say that they is two things
corporal Ashley when I got great prices
and franchise Ashley wedding and then
and then have you guys have you guys
built a private label we work toward it
with some Ashley Furniture of turning
the section called our rooms Ashley
waxed we provide these tags were the
only ones that can have it I think
within 300 miles something like that
we've been working toward that goal of
just snacks and the actually tags all
together but the radar room stat you
know I'm the same keep going and more or
less creating that brand love that day
this is us this is it naturally I
realized somebody can lift a cushion
they can figure it out but most people
shop on the furniture they don't in my
eyes they don't know the difference
between coaster Ashley or Jim Bob I
never I have no yeah yeah they sound
they like
it looks good let's go yeah it's all
about the problem to me I mean we're not
making property because mr. Lindsey grew
up in the day of discount the way my dad
did yeah it's what my dad did to me by
cops for $400 we sell it for 125 bucks
it was all about this big numbers end of
the day but you didn't make any damn I
was trying to make us much more probably
like sales is possible yeah yep buy all
this and I know it I'm actually a
believer in it
Boehner me doesn't make any money either
I believe in it you just have to you
have to get the biggest value for it and
then to your point like it also depends
on like what your trunk you know 10%
profit at the end of the year feels
different at four and forty what made
you pivot because there's maybe some
similarities if it came in with an
expansion plan and didn't you originally
think you're gonna have ten wine
libraries yes and then moved in a
different direction was one giant
because the dot-com had way more
potential in it than I anticipated at
the time but you still expanded the one
that you had dramatically at 32,000
square feet an hour
yeah but moments in time right like like
I would mean that I would I mean if I
could decrease this if I could eliminate
the second floor of my dad's store right
now I would I just I just think that
them making the business the buying why
are you buying the building just cause
you're young and like [ __ ] it let me
just buy an asset yeah it's an essence
yeah I think it's right I and why cuz
the landlord selling landlord selling
the mr. Lindsey never owned it
no he's a different guy like he's out of
Birmingham but it was actually
recenter and he doesn't live he doesn't
live in Panama City it's out there empty
for sale for a really really long time
and we were in the same Plaza and our
lease was up and so we started debating
and we're like well I mean it just at
the time makes it cool to go ahead and
purchase and you did that already or I
mean we're still paying obviously of
course but you did buy it you dope I got
it oh great awesome
I said then the same owner actually has
a piece of property next door
still wooded but my long-term goals by
that tear all the woods down and make
that the warehouse
so then I can take the wall back down if
you do not if you do not build a private
brand you will lose if you don't make a
massive commitment to building a brand
you will lose
I genuinely believe that you're making
such an investment in a decreasing asset
to where the future is going you have to
at all costs and whether you start light
with using Ashley to do it for you
and you graduate one day because there's
a third part you know senior partner
here and her or his job is to go to
China and because she used to work at
Ashley and now she's your creator of
product she comes back with a bubble
wrap based you know you know the cool
you know fabric this you know five
people couches instead of one or
foldable or that I saw that one company
you can make the couch in a box right
there expandable you know so whatever it
is I'm gonna tell you right now
one man's point of view what I think you
paid for you have to figure out what to
do with some of your space that does not
do what you do now that has the sol-fa
old thinking co-working space a cafe
number two you have to figure out calm
and I mean like yes the yes we end up I
apologize and yes of course and then
number three you have to create a
private label name it after some kids
grandkids
uncle Lindsay himself maybe when you
rebrand the company maybe that's the
private label itself who the hell knows
it will be your only asset you're so
young it's going to be your asset in 30
years your private label business will
be more valuable than your real estate
are you able to
for something above and beyond the
actual product so to me we're this the
next logical place to have a
conversation is the service of room
design you know the thing that makes
somebody actually buy from you and pay
$35 more is that they value the hundred
dollar room design fee from Sara that
you built up on YouTube and Facebook and
Sarah is your Sara okay so one of the
things I'm you know this is a very
comfortable zone for me to strategize
around because I lived it service
layered on top of retail is a very big
deal for you because you know if you go
far out with the shipping you know me
sing in my 20 single guy and I want to
put like furniture I don't know what the
[ __ ] to put it like whatever like if I
knew that I could spend an extra hundred
bucks because the website showed a video
and she's like I'm Karen I'll literally
come to your house for a next 100 bucks
on top of your thousand dollar order and
it's super worth it because I'll Feng
Shui this and I'll may this and I'll
whatever the hell it is I think you need
to start debating that I mean everything
that I'm hearing from your business is
what I love because you've got like the
foundational aspect of it down but you
guys are smart and realized that's like
a rat race like if you stayed if you
keep doing the business the way you're
exactly doing it there'll be good years
there'll be bad years but like it all is
getting trickled away every single day
right it's kind of why I gotta do a wine
club for my dad right he needed an
injection this last summer because he
needed more cash to be more marketing
and I created a wine club that generated
two million dollars for him every single
month he's getting that and we're able
to use those dollars to market and now
we're starting to got it you need those
injections you need you need to to me it
calm it's not an injection that calms
our [ __ ] artery that runs like it's
not like back to a body like like calm
is like I don't know a heart like a
[ __ ] like what else can't you live be
can live with one right yeah so I'm
thinking about
like what else can't you live without
fair it's like so to me no that's
perfect the retail store is the heart
and the brain right the heart and the
brain and the heart could be the store
in the brain could be the dot-com I like
the analogy of that and like that is not
like that's not being creative
that's just table stakes adding a
service on top of with videos with you
too because you never go away and a new
interior designer adding a private label
taking 5000 square feet in your store
and literally going rogue as [ __ ] like I
don't know put a fitness thing and it's
like could you imagine if you put like
the only influencers in Fitness there
are on Instagram now could you imagine
if you just put a fitness area in there
and literally was an essence a free
workout club like a child or you start
like your client wall also in it the
furniture store yeah makes [ __ ] sense
you got to give them another reason to
come when I've been saying that the last
like six eight months yes we need to
become a destination yeah
you're too big 85,000 square feet and I
apologize real quick because I don't
want to lose the thought and if you
reverse engineer who your clients are
then you can really make it good meaning
you know that's why I like classes we're
starting to play with a little bit at
Wine Library like you know if you're
doing business classes it's just you
know like there's a you know like you
think about like who you want because
like if you do you know like one of the
side did something for the last year
they're at Wine Library as well where
I'm running Facebook Ads to give away
ten dollars worth of free food
straight-up walk in get some sausage get
some she's like get some pickles I'm
like 909 and welcome to register scan a
barcode and you're out and striving my
dad crazy
because because I think you'll love this
status he goes the [ __ ] Russians are
coming in here and they're sending their
aunt and their uncle I'm like dad the
whites and the african-americans and
Latinos and they're also doing it but
the Russians rub you the wrong way
because I know because they're speaking
Russian he doesn't know that he can
understand him and then like these and
they're saying things like these [ __ ]
idiots they don't realize we're getting
fifty dollars worth of free food and I'm
saying to my dad I go dad you don't get
it if you run the numbers if you look at
the receipts we're making enough on the
added sales for the people that aren't
breaking the system and are buying $280
for the stuff on top of it and we're
running it in hours where we don't have
people coming in and it's great for all
the people driving by our Highway seeing
a full parking lot at 10 a.m.
got it Brant um I think about Brant you
know you live in Springfield you've now
started working shopping at Kings to
supermarket started having wine hurt our
business makes sense right convenience
they're four five six seven dollars a
bottle more but you're it's an affluent
area and like I don't want to go to wine
library for ten minutes and pay $7 less
on a seventeen dollar item I'm rich
right like and so a person driving to
King's to their food market at 9:30 5:00
in the morning and seeing a full wine
library parking lot that works
uh-huh they're like I just had anybody
like a human like oh they're busy
they're busy so food trucks is another
thing that's really worked for me I
don't know we you're parking you own the
building is it's a it's a shopping
center a free-standing store so you
don't own the shopping center kept a lot
of parking can I make a huge huge random
idea you should do food truck events in
your parking lot on weekends there's so
many food truck businesses in Florida go
on Twitter find them go in and see them
find them invite them offer them free
space be like hey come you know you know
and then market it do you have an email
newsletter for your customers okay we
have to do that ASIS highly highly do
you have any you have a car a card a
membership card you have no data on your
cost
this is great this is so fun for me you
have to do how bad is your POS system
old school old school you should have
every single customers information every
son customer you have a high ticket item
what's the average sale [ __ ] me
this is great awesome purchases a year
right can you sell something less
expensive can you make them can we come
up with a signature product what happens
when it snows like can you like it
doesn't snow in Florida fans and they
orchid it like you go that route if you
don't go into that put you don't go
hardware e that way right Community
College Oh actually Florida State has a
branch there Oh
buses students before they move into
doors every year
god there's so much you can be doing
cool your arms it's a Commuter it's a
Commuter FSU rentals rentals yeah and
then we have a lot of new developments
going on that back-to-school dress when
you send buses bring hundreds of
students this shop Gary what do you
think about this the new brand it's it's
an econ or digital company that happens
to have a retail location it's
completely a different thinking not that
you have a retail store that has a
website it's an econ company that
happens that happens to have a retail
location
that's what Wine Library became yeah
just just the dynamic of what we do
every day
and what I live every day on the front
lines I just feel like we gotta get
there so here's what I would say a
couple things you have to wrap your head
around you're gonna have to hire
somebody to run your comm you're gonna
have to have too much expertise to
compete it's not 1997 anymore where like
everybody was kind of figuring it out
you have to you're gonna compete you're
gonna need something you know and the
good news is there's a lot of young
bucks out there who will love the
autonomy and will flat out think I'll
take this job cuz I'll be able to learn
everything and I'll leave in three years
and honestly that's a good trade good
for you good for them like you know that
I do believe in parts of the country you
can get somebody that's very
knowledgeable bless you for forty to
sixty thousand which would be we would
laugh he really cost us 250 for those
skills but I do think it's out there I
do I really do you got to find the right
kid or the right retiree or like there's
a million different things you know
because that's my biggest thing like the
website we have now we only have seven
to ten of our companies on there because
that's all the catalogs that the website
company has built but that's a ten is
all they allow me on there so there are
so many more brands - what are you use
for that because I couldn't figure out
like what the company its Renaissance
the only reason why why you use that and
not like are there more catered to the
furniture industry so they already had
like the catalogs built so all I had to
say was okay at these companies and then
here's my markup and then it was done I
didn't have to send them a bunch of
pictures I didn't have to say well we
think that we can we can think like
Shopify
gives you tremendous platform and then
on top of that you could building that
catalog build catalogs that are twenty
five thousand items you know and and
it's an investment once you make that
investment
the platform because right now you're
getting boxed in yes solutions right so
should see it exactly except from gay
let's quickly shift gears to Brent right
like what kind of brand are you
envisioning you can't build what do you
have in your guts right what is it that
you have that differentiates yourself
from from others whether it's in real
life or online give us good thinking
initial thinking of them what do you
want to stand for I would personally
like to stand for I mean being there for
the customer I need to say this but
don't always think the customer is right
but I want them to have a good shopping
experience this is a lot of money two
hundred five hundred dollars could mean
the world to somebody and I want them to
know that we appreciate them spending
their hard-earned money our store on us
we want to give them a great experience
we want them to not leave and be pissed
off some people are just unreasonable so
you can't help everybody but helping a
majority of our customers get what they
need and not have to go to Amazon to buy
sheets and not having to go to Walmart
to get pillows we want to be I want to
be the all-in-one so what I'm what I'm
hearing is customer care right being
there for customer was the first thing
that we said it seems like it's in your
heart
so
here then value for money but this is a
shopping experience with an item on
selection all right so good excellent
what what talk to us about your current
customer experience because that's what
we've been hearing a lot about I'm
saying I mean it's pretty good right now
my assistant she's she's chatty Cathy's
and I suppose
take us through customer experience when
she walks into your store what happens
they get greeted at the door you have a
person standing there really try to we
are always make sure of somebody how
many people do you have on the floor try
to have four to five one three just quit
well and this is sort of a part that
I've been waiting on because this is the
shittiest thing we have animosity Beach
is small there's a lot of drug addicts
educated people down there I mean that's
very very minimal to find somebody who
even wants to get off their ass hustle
and yeah and show up to work sorry i get
it much less somebody who's going to
come in there and be what we this afford
to effort or have the vision sort of
wants in them and the growth that we
want to have you know I'm to a place
where we we have to hire warm bodies
like hire these people a million years
five or ten years ago yeah but just how
you know what you said you know
so we we had a very similar situation
with Wine Library we did something that
came unnatural to us if we went to the
sphere a little bit further paid a
little more we recruited a little bit
different we went to some colleges
further out I'll go around we now have
more least of all our employees travel
within 15 minutes we have plenty of
people commuting 40 minutes we're kind
of paying a little bit more to subsidize
that travel cost but it really worked
for us I would really look at you know
whether it's community colleges or other
things it's gonna cost you more money
but you're gonna be the deltas bet like
how much how much would that kind of
person what would you pay that minimum
weight like what's the what's that
entry-level I would highly recommend
going further out and going 14 you're
just gonna win there's no Commission
type there's already it's just just how
they get mattress you know like mattress
fits of warranties fists and different
things like that I mean you know they've
make up to a hundred dollars on one
mattress oh really
I want to go sell mattress really
hundred [ __ ] but I think where we
naturally disconnect comps because
you've got the quality of 10 or $12 an
hour person here even though that you're
dying on that hundred dollar carry they
can obtain that huh
make sense make sense make sense I think
it's about kissing more frogs it worked
for us I told Britt like I was like
Brandon we just need to hire way more
Brandon like you've been in our business
for 20 years I don't know how long
you've been it but like you know you get
caught in your old habits it's very hard
it retailed not to think about what you
used to get for 850 an hour like I know
what you're going through this is why
this works for me is when I can give
this advice it worked we went to Fort we
went to 14 we went further out our
circle ton of people suck [ __ ] still but
but we got over the course of a year 71
people in 70 people in and like four
were foot
nominal and now there are Foundation and
we're gonna get to three forty years out
of them and yeah well and I think coming
out of you know coming out of mr.
Lindsay era that was a lot of what it
was I mean Jim that old school a you
know wow you know you [ __ ] you meditate
your life basically oh yeah my dad
literally paid people to read them fifty
five fifty an hour back in the day when
I started and thought they should treat
it like it was their own store are you -
for me I was two bucks a business watch
I was like I was supposed to pay him
dude honestly I swear to god that's a
great idea I like um I I think
everything like I would basically look
at the in the slick the area and try to
figure out what's underserved
is there one is there one coffee shop
two little is there one Jim too little
is there one salad you know like
SoulCycle like type of bicycle like like
is there not is there no co-working
space to me all of its interesting I
just know for a fact that when you have
that kind of an asset of 85,000 square
feet there's more you can do you know
what what we're not talking about yet is
our ability to help you once you hire
somebody to run Facebook ads they're the
best local ads you could ever imagine
all the things that mr. Lindsey did with
Direct Mail and coupons or whatever the
[ __ ] he did to build up the business 30
40 years ago like that I did as well
like it works it just works and so like
but when you have something to say it's
better like you know targeting people
that live within a 20 mile radius that
are into you know you know CrossFit that
you now have a free gym in the middle of
your store is a conversation so I think
that's right severe I think I think to
me what I try to get out of my time here
is the most macro we're gonna be
together again but like to me between
now and the time we get to see you again
I want I want the framework I see you
guys taking notes I want to know what
we're doing with calm it's it's the
brain can't can't be a person without
brain I want to know how you're thinking
about the physical location to do
something else with it I want to know
how you're thinking about
the private label and I want to know
that those to me to three and then the
next tier gets into making sure we get
data from everybody the strategy around
hiring a little bit further out you know
that's your business but what's the blue
truck thing would [ __ ] work
you know everyone guy primary and we
asked him and he's like I can yeah I
can't put it in a schedule we missed LA
too many spots or so I respect that so
thank you thank you I wanted because
your parking lot busy on the weekends
yeah mm-hmm
like for the center well I think that's
really gonna improve it's an older
shopping center they're putting uh some
kind of electric go-kart track and
actually on our whole bill we're still
in the same shopping center that the old
location that we leased was there's a
Dollar General there the holy problem is
we're on the far end of that shot like
what I was telling you people were like
where are you
we're in mark plot you'll never believe
this my dad's liquor store his first one
was in Clark New Jersey the whole
shopping center was over here you'd come
from the road here and like all the
stores are here and my dad's ago so is
here three standing in the same shopping
center and so I get it man [ __ ] I get it
and my store my library was freestanding
and all the stores I competed against
would have like a Whole Foods and the
shopping like I always be pissed I'd be
like [ __ ] those suckers suck they get
all this by accident business I get
every [ __ ] customer I have them
earning you know so then they built a
half of Lee bridge that comes like same
store sets here the bridge comes up and
goes this way so it's even worse that's
the corner so I mean if you're a head
and bless you don't even see it it's
really no way to turn in there unless
you turn it light up here let me get you
the shine there otherwise you have to
somebody I can trust
oh yeah they're just still are you are
you advertising where Wow
Facebook and then in goes to Instagram
texting program of our shows on TV
commercial on radio and what do you
don't do what he had was I stopped that
stop what you know yeah so I wanted to
try different things yeah but I quit yo
nineteen billboards and how that's great
old like old deals like got some good
locked in deals right yeah I like
outdoor well it's priced right well a
little jingle and the whole nine yards
it's been around these six years little
kids you know jingle we hear people say
that what's the Jim can I hear it yeah
you know you guys heard it will say I
don't know loses furniture I mean you
know the Knicks got a solid would be
like your any you you must not watch TV
listen radio or drive down the road so
you know how can you not know about
Lindsay's furniture but you might not be
in the consideration set of buying I
don't know any furniture just I don't
even know a name of the furniture store
well burgers on my own
yeah Bob's discount like like I have
never bought furniture we won't flying
again I know that one but like but like
like that look I've never heard of
Ashley's have no idea what the [ __ ]
you're talking at you okay I don't know
what I know I remember those and I think
a lot of these players are also regional
now you're getting newer furniture
stores by wayfarer that does well wait
there's a problem because they're the of
course I made a lot of money on the
stock it has gone up like this right
you're winning they're losing
waitis - pointer to any sort of athletic
attribution modeling to be able were
looking at your media being and we'll
figure out the effectiveness of that
media absolutely not no way because they
don't have the date on the other part
right they're not collecting that data
so even even when you you know even when
you can take it's hard with Facebook do
they can they come with like a coupon or
something to the store and you give them
like I don't know $10 off of this sofa
or hundred dollars you're on right now
20% off is it coupon or is it a verbal
7oz oh but again you're not collecting
the data at the register so you're not
sure you're getting the transactional
benefit but not that yeah but you're on
the invoice you're giving them that 10%
discount so if you kind of look back at
that handwritten invoice you would see
that it was 10% this kind of it right
like March we did a scratch-off
st. Patrick's I love you I love that
[ __ ] man I'm telling you like that's the
[ __ ] I do I believe in that [ __ ] you
know pretty much everybody used it I
don't think there was I saw a couple of
the trash but everything what do you
mean how did they get the scratch off
when they walked in the door
you gave a scratch up and they scratch
drop it I would say 10 15 20 percent off
free delivery and then we had a fifteen
hundred dollar shopping sprees let
somebody want it yeah then they lose
their [ __ ] yeah
somebody woman there was actually four
or five in there we only gave out these
things once again I think they all buy
condos I would send to reset a [ __ ]
you know like my that would senator like
Las Vega I would Center in a napa she's
my assistant so we've been like a second
office and like within the store just
for like a checkout window and he goes
are you putting her in there is it no no
I said what I need somebody I'm like I
need her right there like my Google
assistant I get it my treat though
remember that your new name is Alexis
yeah yeah couple of other questions so
girls might be limited by our geographic
location right so we need to understand
then yeah what's happening with it so
central
no I'm sorry is it like somebody no no I
did my way that you say it Sheva I
didn't say that this is I'm saying that
this is an avenue that we have to
explore understand what is our
geographic limitation who is our
competition and your land issue all
right
how far do you want to go like 10 15
years down
that's exactly right Dennis who do you
want to be
that 100 in the country okay good so
then because that will calibrate our
approach I think that that needs to be
debated for a second because I think
it's the right answer from entrepreneurs
but I think we actually should talk
about it for a second because this is
where I think I can help
that's super arbitrary hundreds like a
good number I get it I actually think
you need to ask us like here is why
vaynermedia my library really really won
cuz I didn't need any money
and I don't mean it's because I already
had money it's cuz I don't need any
money how much profit is the business
making and obviously you're running your
lifestyle through it you're paying
yourself to be able to great like the
profit that it makes at the end of the
year you're kind of rolling back in a
business or are you taking that out for
whatever is you know right so so the
your lifestyle is predicated on the
salaries you guys have created right but
you're also paying off you've also
purchased a really good asset right
you're you're paying off that you know
mortgage through that you know that's
dragging into your profit right this is
literally my [ __ ] dad's business
no ABC but like the world coming down
their throat I'm calm
you know what's one good thing about the
liquor businesses its regulated so it's
not fun there is no way fair there's no
liquor leader because it's [ __ ]
fragmentation at scale protected by loss
I think one thing that I think you
should really think about with each
other securely partners in crime I would
highly recommend mapping out how much
money you want to take home over the
next 20 years I'm not kidding
like number by number by the way I don't
care if it goes down I know nothing
about you like like I'm making less
money than I have because I have a
vision and everyone's allowed to do
whatever they want it would really
really really help because the number
one thing that you have to do just to
win in my opinion
to invest every dollar properly to
maximize your growth the more dollars
you have the more you can invest it's
the scrutiny of your expenses and what
you're doing on the advertising front
and then into what to me it's very
simple create containers that's back to
calm something in store private label
those are the containers and then what
do you spend money on to make those
containers successful got it
and so you know what's a very unique
thing I'm saying it's more for the team
because they get them in right place
vaynermedia was built very uniquely
there haven't been many people that have
come into the advertising space that
really saw an opportunity to leverage
their personal brand as a gateway
branding mechanism to a large fortune
500 consumer set and then converted like
so like I spent like when we look at our
P&L my team there's an expensive
line-item it's not the kind of thing
that other companies have but they have
a new business team that has and so like
but I knew what containers I had what I
was trying to accomplish and then I
started spending against those
containers building a.com you know right
now with that little of margin and me
assuming back to a family business like
you know get I understand the size here
it's not like you guys are rolling and
buying mansions and Porsches well guess
what a new POS system hiring a full-time
calm person the capital expenses of
doing something new inside the store
that might cost renovations I'm not so
sold that you have the cash flow for all
of that and so then I say to myself okay
what are they spending money on for
advertising I believe some of it is way
less valuable than you think because you
can't measure it right now so you might
feel 19 billboards are awesome and they
might not be or they might be maybe it's
actually 29 and no commercials maybe
it's just commercials how much are you
spending on marketing
a year roughly thirty thirty four
thousand I think it was thirty five
thousand a month and what's it broken
down to it's 25 percent digital 25
percent TV out of hole waiting for 16
percent
yeah and what do you think's working the
best and what do you think is working
the work and the worst out of your
advertising if you just had a gas rate
rate Radio Pandora 14 television 24
digital 24 I mean why are we doing
Pandora I did it at the end of 16
beginning of 17 is it targeted local it
was yeah and wasn't working yeah
so I stopped okay I love that you test
yet it's so smart made 100% forever well
and like I get a little scared because
we do so much them should I don't want
to drop this cuz what if that was
working and that it takes three more
months active than that and that's why I
here's what I would tell you I'm
convinced that you're 34 can be 15 do
exactly what it's doing
I just don't know how yet and then all
of a sudden that 20 becomes 240 and that
240 pays for our POS it pays for 49 year
old young Sabir who can like actually be
their day in a day out you know right
let's go in here back I'm impressed
I mean gets warmer so you know look like
dr. evil when I so I think that's where
you have to look at a little bit I think
it's gonna cost you a little bit more
for staff if you go down my rat and go
1415 outside but I think you'll get that
back and people you know 15 14 guy guys
and gals do care a little bit more about
that hundred to your point which means
you're selling an extra mattress you're
not give them 100 for heckle hacks and
giggles it's matters for your business I
think still going back to the dish
because even financing might be an
option right if the vision is there if
the mechanics of it are there too so
it's not necessarily financing tomorrow
right it might be three years down the
road when we have the brand when we have
all of those private label rights
running then all of a sudden you're
ready look I think I think that's
probably right I think what we need to
do here as a team is figure out you know
if that's truly three years from now
let's say arbitrarily like I don't have
a whole lot of energy to like it too
overly worried about that right now cuz
it's just further away I mean to me it's
just like the for the 34k month in
marketing is awfully interesting mm-hmm
because when you have a legendary
business that's been in the same general
location for how many years but you've
been in the same shopping center for oh
you move from us we were like it was in
the middle of the shopping center yep up
until six I got it Buford down at the
end but you're still in that same
shopping center and how long six you
said that years before that were was it
that's we started six years ago that was
one I totally understand you know to to
me
okay got it that is a little bit
different it'll be interesting to see
the advertised I mean that's your
biggest expense you know your mortgage
you know your advertising you got your
payroll right inventory how are you guys
you know actually that's a good one yeah
I know got a run in a second but like
that one helped us quite a bit at a at
Wine Library
you know old-school thinking is you said
it the same way that I think about it my
dad thinks about it inventory paid for
it's an asset right next question
in torreón have yeah and why how much
inventory yeah how much it meant are you
holding I know let's talk about it
goes back from that comes back from mr.
Lindsey I mean Amanda knows big part in
this has all really happened over the
passion I believe it the changes and
everything because mr. Lindsey opened
that place six years ago was still in
the game pretty seriously understood why
then why is he out of the game just got
older is he sick he's okay almost he's
just [ __ ] tired yeah it's like [ __ ]
it because I got believe you can do it
yeah yeah yeah music finally I found
somebody can do something yes or no
video and how long have you been in the
business I'd only been in furniture
business three years how very
interesting one beer but I get it but
like we was a Hotpoint last week buy
furniture you know all the new stuff you
see it then you get it you know probably
August September Jim would go to those
markets and he didn't give a damn if he
spent $800,000 phone Shh oh [ __ ] from
1970 that nobody even wants he just
would just go bye-bye 50 bucks instead
of hundred he loved clothes out then it
was a closeout for a reason well he
believed in a salesmanship I mean I
bought clothes outs like I love clothes
outs because I knew I could sell them
when nobody else could I mean he didn't
go to eat he didn't go out of business
he just knew that he would be able to
somebody come in and want to buy
something he would be like don't buy
that buy this for 55 bucks and worse
still still still okay this no that's
great yeah let's talk about it how much
how much when you come back here I want
to see how much inventory you have that
you deem [ __ ]
retail cost cost and retail how much you
think good I know I know it could be you
could be way up 500 to a million old
inventory yes probably
well no I'm thinking yeah yeah six years
or old into 25 years um there's probably
[ __ ] in there from 2015 like if I had to
go back and find a price because it's
just continued or it closed out I would
have to go to 2015 I'm so after ten so
after ten somebody would put this same
and so the 10 sale brand got killed
yeah right I get well we changed it last
year to one like our annual sale we
actually put the [ __ ] out there and that
we were able to give up we've counted
and it's older people we heard a lot of
comments
yeah okay so we're talking about
serendipity before so there's this
company that I write checks to like
we're fair company and their address is
1202 Gary Avenue Suite five suite five
that is a good carnival finding that
company Jimmy James
I'm super pumped right now you've given
me a real light I'm telling you right
now that half a million to a million and
you think that's cost I think you'll get
you're guessing
it's fine and would would it be
appropriate to think that you're gonna
have to sell that for like 50 cents on
the dollar less than the cost to like
yeah you really this is a real
opportunity guys like like this is where
a lot of retail stores lose they put
their head in the sand because they
don't want to think about it because
they know it's a [ __ ] mess meanwhile
it's the place where like you could give
it away and change your business
there's so I mean you ever saying you've
given me mo you know how much better
your radio campaign will work that says
we're giving away a ten thousand dollars
worth of furniture in the first hour
this Saturday like you've got a mo
you've got amp you've got two things
that I need this is how I build my dad's
business he had the same [ __ ] part
this is [ __ ] deja boo' he had a mo
and he had he's advertising or not
advertising it was either advertising
that wasn't effective or he had no
advertising like again you've already
probably made a commitment to the radio
thing all you have to do is just change
the [ __ ] copy so you pay another
fifty five hundred bucks whatever the
[ __ ] the prices for a new read and the
read is August seventh giving away
10,000 dollars worth of sofas August the
next week August 14th is its couch day
like clean up clean up clean up and and
and you could do a very simple thing you
could price it appropriately and be like
we are doing the buy one get one free
sale we have a whole we will have all to
get one free products in the front you
buy any product that matches that price
you get an equal value of the free
section product you buy $1,500 couch you
get a $1,500 couch for free because you
price it you know that that couch is
really 350 but if it was 1500 at one
point and they're gonna say [ __ ] like
well that's not 15 but
still it's [ __ ] free still you got a
ready good prices and all you're doing
is you're inducing it to sell more of
something else you [ __ ] that's that is
HUGE I'm done could be the 250k that you
can fund whatever grabs oh that's 20%
off you're getting people respond to
free boy yeah funny gets people going I
get it yeah but I'm willing to bet that
part of that 500k to a million not
everything is [ __ ] like there there are
pieces in there that you can't get all
the way I'll see you guys soon unique
thank you such a pleasure
how's it going so far good good great
thank you guys thank you
[Music]